hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast high quality NGS sample prep I
am Judy or Oracle a brutes we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by co veras for more
information please visit co varus inc
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
steering this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green suen a
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Hamid koja
principal scientist Guevara sink dr.
Hamid koja brings years of experience in
hace protocol and kit developments in
the field of molecular biology recently
dr. koja has helped advance ffpe DNA and
RNA extraction by utilizing cove Aras is
patented adaptive focused acoustics
technology to develop a robust protocol
and the true extract purification kits
previously as a research scientist dr.
coach has developed several kits and
high-throughput assays for internal
research initiatives including branched
DNA assay for uncle gene quantification
mass spectrometer based assays for cftr
and other disease mutation analysis kids
for chip chip assays and the true chip
chromatin cheering reagent kits
optimizing chromatin cheering for chips
applications dr. kocha thank you very
much for attending today's webinar and I
sincerely hope will be helpful for
everyone we will take questions
the end of the webinar so please go
ahead and submit your questions either
in English or Chinese and we will try to
get as many through as many as we can so
in today's webinar just looking at the
agenda will discuss a few things well I
will go through and discuss with you and
explain what kavars adaptive focus
technology is and we'll also go through
some of the clinically important
applications such as DNA in RNA sharing
NGS grade ffpe nucleic acid extraction
as well as chromatin cheering for
chromatin immunoprecipitation these
three applications are vastly dependent
on good quality sample prep for engine
for use in NGS and we will go through
these applications and how we have gone
through and optimized these applications
for use so the first thing cabarrus
adaptive focused acoustics the
technology is based on highly developed
technologies such as a therapeutic
ultrasound as well as excuse me
diagnostic ultrasound then therapy
programs such as literacy which uses
high-frequency acoustic to break kidney
stones kumaris technology is adaptive
focus technology is a combination of
both both of these technologies but it's
optimized for biomolecule processing the
technology is a controlled cavitation
driven process and we have over 50
patents issued and patents patents
pending on the technology just to
describe what cavitation is so
cavitation simply put is when you have
acoustic waves traveling through a
liquid medium the pressure waves cause
the dissolved gases to come out of
solution as microscopic air bubbles as
these bubbles grow oscillation collapse
they generated quite a bit of shearing
forces and these shearing forces control
of these shearing forces
to transform acoustic energy into a
mechanical energy so below you see a
video of a cavitation bubble bursting as
well as a picture of a cavitation
bubbles that form using a 60 Hertz
transducer so I quite a few people tend
to confuse collected optical
characteristics with with sauna Gators
that is actually further quite far from
the truth kumar's adaptive focus
statistics or AFA as I will refer to it
from now on it is different in a variety
of different ways first of all if you
look at the acoustic spectrum it is
quite different in terms of the
frequency Kovar cfa operates at 500
kilohertz range traditional sonicator
such as bats alligators and probe sonic
gators tend to operate in 15 to 60
kilohertz frequency in terms of the wave
like these traditional sonicator start
to generate wavelengths that are 10 to
15 centimeters long whereas cabarrus
technology generates wavelengths that
are about a millimeter along so
therefore it is very easy for kavars
technology to focus all the ways to
acoustic waste a very small sample tube
whereas with a star locators and focus
on decatur's that is impossible and
that's why we see a quite a bit of
heating and lack of control and those
technologies so some of the attributes
of cabarrus about the focus acoustic is
that we use the tallest 8.5 megahertz
ultrasonic transducer that is medical
grade it's the same type of transducer
that's used in diagnostic ultrasound and
therapeutic office on the transducer is
designed specially designed so
dramatically geometrically focuses all
the acoustic energies are very small
focal point that is about one
millimeters thick a wide and about the
size of a grain of rice it is a complete
non-contact delivery of controlled
acoustic energy to your sample by
focusing the waves of by using these
high frequency short wavelengths we are
able to control the energy as well as
the thermal event so we can maintain a
isothermal processing of your sample
throughout the process so technology
doesn't matter so really it takes about
one mega pascals of energy to initiate
cavitation so if we look at the three
types of technologies such as tovar CFA
on the left and then back sonicator in
the middle and probe sonicator on the
right you'll notice that what Kivar CFA
requires are only about point 8 watts of
energy to initiate cavitation about
sonic ater which is an unfocused
transducer it requires about a hundred
30 watts of energy to initiate
cavitation that is because most of that
energy is wasted as heat and I'll show
you that on the next slide baksana
caters are quite good and then inquire
about only about five watts of energy to
initiate cavitation however when we look
at the temperature profile of these you
can see the major differences between
that these technologies and kavars so in
this experiment DNA was shared to 200
base pairs using all three different
technologies using published settings
for sharing of DNA on the left hand side
you see cars without the focus acoustics
whereas at the end of the process for
general for sharing DNA which takes
about two hundred basements would take
for that 180 seconds you see there's
there's no temperature differential
between the water bath answers to your
sample to you in the middle you see the
water bath temperature from a bath
sonicator as you can see the different
gradients of temperatures through at the
end of process that is easily exceeding
40 degrees centigrade on the right hand
side you see a
prob sonicator basically with a probe
sonicator you're taking a hot metal rod
and you're sticking it's a small volume
of your sample so the temperature will
fluctuate and raise our about 40-50
degrees c within a matter of seconds
these technologies lack thermal control
and lack of thermal control is can
easily be interpreted as damage to your
sample and lack of reproducibility so
Kovar so dr. focused acoustics along
with it engineered consumables can
manage to share DNA anywhere from a
hundred base pairs to 1.5 k d so these
are for short inserts we have a
specifically designed sample buckles
that mimic the geometry of our
transducers so you get a very efficient
energy transfer from your from the
transducer to your sample tube just
looking at an example of the importance
of these engineered consumable and in
this experiment DNA was shared in one of
our glass micro tubes as well as a pcr
tube and as you can see the difference
within with our technology the
temperature maintains isothermal there
is no company heat gain during the
process or in your sample but within a
PCR tube as you can see will although
the water bath that the temperature
remains at seven degrees the sample
temperature has already exceeded 50
degrees the reason for this is that the
polymers almost all of the plastic
consumables available absorb acoustic
energy very readily and then transfer
that heat as the transfer that energy as
heat your sample and then they behave as
and then they prevent the dissipation of
heat from the samples from your sample
tube back into the water bath so
temperature will increase
over time so let's look at the first the
first application which is NGS grade DNA
shearing that is the critical first step
in sample preparation for
next-generation sequencing was the worse
the technology which is an ideal
controlled fermentation system the
fragmentation is random the distribution
is very tight and the recovery is quite
high this is completely non contact and
the process is highly reproducible not
only from sample to sample and user to
use it but from day to day and from
instruments the instrument across the
different institutes and such there is
no cross contamination or carryover
contamination risk is everything is
carried out and so inflows tubes and a
single platform can be used for sharing
DNA from anywhere from 100 base pairs 25
kb for sequencing fragment as well as
made shared library preparation so you
don't need different technologies or
different types of platforms to achieve
that and the technology is very high
throughput capable and it is designed
and engineered with fragmentation of NGS
fragmentation of DNA four ng s online
looking at some of the data and I'll go
through this quickly and the time the
technology is also very concentration
independent that is you could share DNA
of a wide range of concentrations and
still get the usiness certain setting
and still get the same results and in
this experiment you can see that DNA
shoot at five micrograms two micrograms
and 124 nada grams to two hundred to a
hundred base pairs and as you can see it
does not affect the distribution or
average size of the fragment the same is
true when you're looking at 200 base
pairs there's completely concentration
independent and if you look at the 96
overlay of 200 base for families there
are no dropouts there are no outliers it
is highly reproducible and it always
generates the same fragment distribution
and average fragment size there are
consumables form a pair library
preparation these there are libraries
that are one and a half 25 kb we do have
specifically designed consumables to
achieve one and a half kb 3 kb and 5 kb
DNA fragmentation and looking at these
these are also a very concentration
independent so in this experiment you
see the DNA ranging cousin amount
ranging mass ranging anywhere from 2
micrograms to 20 micrograms shared to
one-and-a-half kb using the same setting
without having any effect on the
distribution or average size it's always
generating the one and a half kb
fragment regardless of the concentration
this is true 42 43 kb fragmentation
using the mini tube blues again white
concentration range the same exact
setting used and no effect on the size
range and distribution by varying the
concentration this is something very
unique to coerce technology and northern
technology such as bath and probe sauna
caters can achieve that because a slight
concentration difference well affect not
only the shearing size ranges
distribution but also the route for
disability the same is true with 5k
defragmentation so here we see 5k b sine
waves being generated using mini to
bread so we do also have GTA GTA a
product called g tube which is the which
is used to generate DNA fragments from 6
kb 228 kb this does not utilize adapter
focused acoustics but it utilizes your
tabletop centrifuge to share DNA so it
is very versatile you can select the DNA
size range by simple
Lee adjusting the speed in the
centrifuge it's highly reproducible it
is very scalable in highly efficient you
can recover ninety percent of your
material will greater than ninety
percent of the material after sharing so
it's a very simple process you basically
put your samples in the g-tube
centrifuges invert is 90 degrees
centrifuge it again and recover your
sample so as you can see by just
adjusting the temperature the RPM you
can adjust the size range of your DNA
fragments looking at some of the data so
here is a data and is showing that how
you can easily adjust from 6kb to 20 kb
fragments by simply adjusting the
revolution the speed of your centrifuge
and the x analyzer data is underneath it
is highly reproducible so here's ten
replicas of DNA fragmented using the GPU
to about 12 kb so as you can see on the
x analyzer traces bottom highly
reproducible no joke on base and it
generates the exactly the same
distribution and average fragment size
we also do have RNA fragmentation which
is a non-chemical its robust and highly
reproducible and utilizes the same
adaptor focused acoustics to share our
me just like DNA there are quite a few
publications as in which scientists have
opted to using this method to fragment
RNA for our lasik applications instead
of using the chemical methods which
require quite a bit of cleanup and quite
a high loss of sample during the cleanup
steps so looking at trouble the data you
can fragment it either messenger RNA or
total RNA into a variety of different
sizes so in this case it's about 200
meters
sighs messenger RNA takes about 80
seconds or as total RNA would require
about 300 seconds to share down to about
200 nucleotides soco virus adaptor
focused acoustic is a complete
fragmentation system for clinically
relevant samples it is concentration
independent DNA shewing random
isothermal cheering that from anywhere
from 100 base pairs to 20 kb it's highly
reproducible there's no risk of
cross-contamination or carryover
contamination the technology is very
advanced than computer controlled
hardware was a very user-friendly
software user authentication and brown
logging that's required for processing
clinical samples it is very high
throughput capacity in automation
friendly technology so let's get to the
next application which is the
abstraction of engineers grade DNA and
RNA from ffpe tissues from
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissues
so as many of you are aware that there's
estimated to be about 1 billion FFPE
samples worldwide it is the most common
method of preserving solid tissue
samples for clinically clinical
diagnostics and research and it has been
used by a clinical pathologist and it
continued will continue to be used by
clinical pathologist I clearly preserve
the tissue morphology it was never
envisioned for use in molecular analysis
but it is an excellent resource for new
genomic insights using NGS however the
DNA extraction has been quite variable
and time-consuming until now looking at
the workflow of traditional methods that
are used to attract the DNA from ffpe
tissues as you can see it is a very
complex three to four they work flow was
a diffusion dependent a passive
diffusion dependent method of removing
have been using very harsh organic
solvents such as Riley or very messy
mineral or
this typically takes five for 30 minutes
and then you have to hydrate this issue
or utilizing several multiple solvent
water incubations that can be anywhere
from two to eight hours if you're
working with large tissue sections such
as biopsy course that might even require
tissue for organization using a blade
for modernizer and such and then the
tissue digestion and cross-linking can
be up to 72 hours long as you can see
it's a very complex of very
time-consuming and these are requiring
dangerous organic solvents the yields
come to be poor with very low
reproducibility and at the end the DNA
quality is not up to par for most NGS
applications so there's been a clinical
critical need for developing a new
method to accommodate the sensitivity in
quality requirements of NGS based
analysis so what we've done is we've
utilized provides adapted focused
acoustics for example for FFPE samples
and we've been able to deliver very
active processing from the critical
first steps one we have developed a
novel razor free tissue capture from
slide so you don't have to utilize
surgical razors or scalpel to release
the tissue from flights we've also
developed a acoustic-based a paraffin
ization that is active in much more
efficient than organic solvents or
mineral oils and this also allows for a
simultaneous tissue rehydration that
that's also done within minutes rather
than ours and it also homogenizers and
access and the digestion of tissues that
is more efficient as well as the nucleic
acid release so the the workflow is
fairly simple as simple as 123 you
collect your samples you transfer to the
micro tube and then you like the
acoustics get rid of the paraffin as
well as rehydrate the tissue this is
a process that takes less than 10
minutes from sample collection through
rehydration the tissue pick which is a
number of feet issue capture method it
is basically utilizes a porous material
that that as you run it across the
tissue sample that's pronounced it on
the flight it absorbs and maintains hold
over that tissue so then you take that
and you transfer it for the micro tube
for capture so it's basically as a
basically a very simple very efficient
method of removing certain regions from
a big fish' section that's what mounted
on slide so typically you don't want to
take the whole tissue you just want to
take the tissue sections that you need
so here's an example of one as you can
see on the right hand side there's those
tissue sections will fully removed using
a single tissue pick and on our website
you can actually see a video of the
tissue pick and how simple it is and
removing and acquiring the tissue
sections from slides this allows you is
a great amount of reproducibility so
just comparing it with a razor blade
remover where you have to remove the
entire section and i wish you pick where
you all knew with the tissue sections
and leads all the facts access power
from behind as you can see the
reproducibility is incredibly higher
inside so you do you that is one big
worried that you no longer have the
paraffin removal stuff is fairly simple
as well so using acoustics as you can
see on the right-hand side a tissue
section scroll mounted in the inside a
place inside a micro tube and then you
can see the after about three hundred
second processing all the paraffin is
released from the tissue is very small
about 25 micron
unless particles that remain suspended
in solution and Laura are inert and will
not affect the subsequent processing so
here's an example that shows the active
versus passive san fran removal on the
right hand side you see an untreated
slide in the middle you see as a section
that's been treated with Kivar therapy
to remove the paraffin and on the right
hand side you see a panel that has used
Eileen and to remove the paraffin and as
you can see based on the
autofluorescence that section has quite
a bit of fluorescence left over which
means there's quite a bit of paraffin
still adhering to the tissue section the
problem with this is that is that the if
you cannot remove the paraffin
completely then efficiently then it's
impossible for the tissue to become
hydrated and therefore it's not
accessible for ponies k digest and
nucleic acid release so by that just
that one step can easily affect not only
the yield but also the quality of the
material that you're extracting but also
the type of DNA that you're extracting
and I'll show that more in the
sequencing results and a little bit so
with the to extract nucleic acids is
sfpd DNA and RNA extraction systems with
the DNA extraction system you can use
either bio biopsy cores of 1.2
millimeters or last or you could use
Scrolls or we'll take this up up to 25
microns or you could use captured tissue
sections from mountain slides the kid
allows you three different DNA
purification options the first option
option eight allows you to cheer and
extract the DNA at the same time it is
that you can extract DNA to do 150 base
pairs 200 base pairs three hundred base
pairs so you share an extract at the
same time there is no transfer steps and
it has a very high DNA extraction yields
for the process physic option B allows
you to attract larger DNA found rules
this is typically about 2 KB and option
B is typically chosen by people who do
microarray analysis or PCR or qpcr based
on analysis in which they require the
larger fragments of DNA extracted from
ffpe tissue there's also option C which
allows you to track genomic DNA as
larger fragments as possible and in our
hands this typically gives the as
fragments of about a kb with the
distribution of all the way up to about
17 to 20 kb fragments of course the
quality of your FFP slice make a
difference on on the quality and size
range that you can extract so there's
three different metrics that are used to
assess quality of FFP a the first one is
yield which basically is a fluorescent
based concentration determination and it
determines the total double-stranded DNA
that's available in your sample there's
of course key pcr-based amplification
assays these value the total amplifier
for DNA of the disclose the quality
measured by qpcr closely resembles the
power the effect of sequencing because
it is polymerase pace so if there are
any inhibitors or damage to the DNA that
prevents the moving of the polymerase
across the VNA this law and the qpcr
based assays will indicate that as well
of course library preparation and
sequencing is the ultimate method of QC
for your DNA desmond isolated looking at
some of the data so here's the three
different options option a B and C
compared against teijin as well as a 4
mega kit as you can see me easily get to
two three four access double-stranded
DNA yields with all three different
options as compared to tides in and for
me
looking at amplify about DNA using qpcr
all three different options very
routinely generate as if at least for
three to six fold higher yields an
amplifier both DNA with all three
different options as compared to our
card kit so we carry down an experiment
in terms of sequencing to see if there
if the results that we've seen in terms
of yield also translates the sequencing
results in terms of covers inside so
what we did was we took kidney and
meters at the feet issue sections as
well as max program tissue from the same
patient obtained from the CHT and unfold
out via ten sections were cut from each
block odd numbers were odd number
sections were processing a hydrogen
current and even number sectional
process using Kivar streets track and we
sequenced nose using whole genome 2 x
100 days verb sequencing on an alumina
high seek looking at the data and
compare notes for flash frozen tissue
from the same patient you can see that
the collagen ffp tissue sections have a
dramatically reduced coverage over 10 x
across the across the genome and this is
more pronounced in areas in genes and
chromosomes that are quite gene branch
so looking at chromosome 19 coverage
which is the most gene rich chromosomal
in the human genome and you can see that
the courage and FFP sections that were
that's what purify these intelligent are
are very continuously and very
significantly lower than 10x coverage
across the entire chromosome whereas the
kavars FFP extracted DNA as well as
fresh for the match the right match for
fresh frozen tissue are predominantly
above connects coverage across the
chromosome so this tells us that there
is a bias involved in your DNA
extraction when you are not extracting
your DNA efficiently if there is
paraffin left over if you're not doing
reverse cross-linking is not as
efficient then you are biasing your
extraction results and of course
sequencing coverage is more uniform so
as you can see here is the kyochon
compared to Kumar's as well as a fresh
frozen tissue you'll notice that the
Cabarrus FFP DNA and fresh frozen tissue
are much more uniform and sequencing as
compared to the Kaizen ffpe the so those
results were all in-house generated but
there was a poster from dana farber at
the ACR 2014 and they basically did a
very similar experiment and their
findings were very similar so they found
that in their hands they were getting
yields that were up to six times higher
than the method which was our collagen
and they also said that the DNA was more
readily available for pcr amplification
the lust GC bias and their library
complexity was higher so this is exactly
the their their abstract for the poster
that they submitted so the same group
just a month or two later are from a crd
sir they published this paper in blood
in which they use the the kavars to
extract for DNA extraction from ffpe
tissue sections just a few months ago
the Nakamura lab at the University of
Chicago they also publish the paper and
clinical cancer research and risk they
used our technology for extracting DNA
for their clinical samples in their
hands based on what the what they had
told us with some samples they were
getting up to a tenfold increase in
yield as compared to the collagen method
so this process is very automation ready
we have been able to automate this
process using a perkin-elmer dick
committed and you can easily extract 96
samples in less than five hours
DNA it's very scalable and it can be
fully automated and its features
basically a very high yield high quality
in high-end profile DNA you can do
neither a single sample using the kids
or you can utilize the automation one
automation right in a collision which is
a deed extraction methods 0 in this data
we compared it to across a wide range of
different tissue samples using an
automated as well as a manual method and
as you can see they're very much similar
in terms of the yield for each of those
section pipes there is an RNA extraction
king as well so it is very simple and
automatable and very similar to the DNA
extraction kit and involves octave
paraffin removal and you can use it
separately or in conjunction with the to
abstract FFP DNA and RNA from the same
tissue sections and looking at some of
the data and here's a 22 different
kidney sections comparing it to a
hydrogen using a Cuban analysis you can
see that the yields are significantly
higher by up a hundred percent but using
rt-pcr method we see an improvement of
over two hundred percent in terms of on
profile good quality RNA same is true
with other tissue sections such as
kidney and run so in this case we're
looking at the qubit I say in terms of
the yields they're looking at rt-pcr but
I also DV 200 which is significantly
higher as compared to archives and
extracted method DB 200 is the method
that's now being utilized by alumina for
determining the quality of RNA products
from ffpe so the concert is basically a
percentage of the materials over 200
nucleotides so the two
traction nucleic acid is a system it's a
standardized workflow for in just called
NGS grade nucleic acid Rhea extraction
from the 50s issues it's a highly
efficient if abs paraffin removal which
is robust not and you thought does not
utilize hazardous organic solvents it's
a complete tissue hydration system which
enables complete foreigners k digestion
is a result therefore results and a
maximum music acid release and quality
it does generate NGS quality nucleic
acids so NGS grade it's basically
uniform in a dollar general uniform
genome coverage and the library library
complexity will be very high and
unbiased so one of the takeaway notes
for this is that if you have precious of
a few samples then you're extracting
nucleic acid quality is directly related
to the big paralyzation technologies and
a bass active depersonalization does
work so next the next application will
cover which is also mgs phase is a
chromatin sharing it is the kavars about
the focus acoustics has proven to be a
very good tool and sharing chromatin for
chip chip seek applications so if we
look at a chip workflow the workflow
hasn't changed much it's fairly simple
you culture the salt across like you
like to share the chromatin we did
analysis and immunoprecipitated
precipitation you reverse the cross legs
purified and then you send your sample
box for sequencing it's a very
complicated time consuming multivariable
process that can easily be affected by
any of the upstream application
processors so but if you look at the
entire workflow the most critical step
is the chromatid sharing stuff because
if the shearing does not work you
typically will go back in process
again so what we've done is we've
separated the entire workflow into three
different sections the first section
which is the critical steps involved the
culturing the cross-linking with formato
formaldehyde cell lysis information
sharing and then you analyze the sharing
in the new IP for purification and
analysis those are all downstream
methods that can easily be affected by
any errors or any issue variable changes
in the critical steps so currently high
energy probe and bass fornicators as
well as automatic digestion has been
used to share chromatin these methods do
have their their job back so the magic
method that's how the fragmentation
biases women publication it generates a
very low resolution map of your epitope
binding but it cannot be used with fixed
chromatin because fixation best cost
their attendance that program stands and
alexander vast fornicators are very high
energy they have thermal control issues
and reproducibility issues as many of
you have used by fabricators on the
forecheck would have known it back
sonicator is also the transducers tend
to degrade over time so the same
applications or the same processing that
gave you great results previously will
no longer do so probe sauna caters
basically as i mentioned earlier you're
basically putting in a hot metal rod and
contact for the limited sample so
thermal control is very difficult with a
probe sonicator also there's also cross
contamination issues because it is a
contact based method and then there's
kavars adapted focused acoustics which
is a focused controllable energy source
is isothermal it's close to processing
and very reproducible so it is so
optimizing the critical first steps and
it doesn't prove the rupert disability
while maintaining the epitope integrity
which is important in chip so the
freezing the critical steps of chip
sample preparation first one is
optimizing formaldehyde fixation
the first thing is the use of methanol
free formaldehyde too many labs use
methanol stabilized formaldehyde which
is the wrong type of formaldehyde to use
and also you want to use the fixation
buffer that prevents themselves from
clumping during during fixation the
second step optimized lysis you want to
be able to use a licensed method that's
gentle there are licensed else but
maintain the nuclei in fact so that you
could have a good nuclei isolation and
the third being optimized chromatin
cheering you want to be sheared akroma
10 while maintaining the epitope
integrity without ripping the proteins
from the DNA and you also want to
eliminate the need to dilute the
chromatin prior to IP so the effects of
methanol and chromatin fixation is
profound methanol itself is a fixative
but it also increases the south
permeability so it makes the fixation it
renders the fixation even more potent so
here's an example in which we we fix
themselves with methanol continued
formaldehyde as compared to methanol
free and as you can see the difference
in terms of the shearing profiles here
in time course you can see the
difference that was methanol containing
formaldehyde which is the bottom panel
you can see that the chromatin is fairly
over fixed and during that same time and
the problem with that over fixed
chromatin is that it still serves as a
great source for IP so therefore those
large fragments r.i.p preferentially
over your small fragments therefore
requiring a secondary shearing before
your sequencing and that increases
increases reduces the resolution of your
chip see so fixation is very much
sunlight independence all files do not
fix the same way and you have to
empirically determine the optimal
fixation time for your
outside it is also episodes dependent
some proteins nah nah proteins fix the
same way and over fixation can affect
antibody binding because over fixation
can change the protein shake therefore
some proteins will not be recognized as
efficiently by antibody so by reducing
the fixation time you're making more
chromatin available for your shins and
this experiment is the time course a
fixation from 0 to 20 minutes and as you
can see as you increase the fixation
time you increase the percent of
fragments that are about to kb which in
our case it shows the extent of over
fixation looking at that more
graphically as you can see as you fix or
longer than five minutes you have a
significant reduction in the amounts of
fragments that are shared to the 200 150
to seven hundred base pairs which is
optimal for chip seek and at the same
time you're increasing the percentage of
fragments that are seven hundreds of 7
kb which shows the over fixed chromatin
that is highly resistant to sharing but
it still maintains quite a bit of
misogyny city which means it'll always
gets old down preferentially over the
smaller sheared fragments that might
contain a single episodes over fixation
also affects this affects nonspecific
binding of evidence so as you open fix
it this has been published previously
you significantly increase the
background IP and implications of this
is that you can get really false
positive IP signal and both gypsy
kinship qpcr but you can also mask week
epitope interactions due to the
increased and background you can utilize
by having the fixation optimized you can
use the same protocol for IP of for
checking for histone modification and
raised rare child scripts and this
example of looking at for 30 minutes you
can see that after 10 minutes
you have a severe reduction and histone
modification IP so and the same is true
that after about five minutes at you
looking for transcription factors the
signal the IP drops the efficiency drop
significantly after five minutes
fixation so it's always advise that you
empirically determine the optimal
fixation time for your cell line and
your epitope of interest looking at some
of the examples of lysis so the license
versus nuclear preparation nuclear
corporation versus one stop Isis or this
experiment as you can see that not doing
an equal nuclei prep and tries to
licensure at the same time using it for
our system does not work because that
methodology was developed for bath and
from alligators and destroy everything
so in this case but the 10 minutes
cross-linking and sharing on the left
panel as you can see in getting a very
nice gradual reduction in size over time
so with the from sonic area where is it
takes 40 minutes to share down with to
100 and 300 base pairs with a coercive
for acoustics air p you can achieve that
in 12 and 12 minutes there are there's
also other methods of lysis lighting
design switches and osmotic based slices
using a mild detergent method osmotic
paid license works well with where is
large cells such as hot C 2 and so on
but with small cells such as to nine
threes and blood vessels it just does
not work automatic license without work
as efficiently therefore you cannot get
to cheering so in this case and osmotic
lysis protocol on the left hand side was
used as a collage technology and it just
does not work so as you can see that the
fusing a mild detergent nuclei isolation
method within eight minutes you're
getting most of your families shared and
far between a hundred and four hundred
base pairs in this case so good sharing
you proceed
feedback sharing you go back and repeat
the whole process so it is very possible
to be able to optimize this whole
process within a matter of a week so
sharing buffered also has an effect on
IT so in this experiment DNA chromatin
was sheared using a very SPS
concentration and then normalized then
we did an IP using Sue's 12 or
transcription factor as you can see if
you share with a greater car at the s
concentration your your solubilizing
more of your epitope so therefore your
enrichment will be significantly reduced
so the less SBS you use the last surgeon
use and you're sharing buffer the
greater the amount of episodes you'll
have love for I see so some of the
sharing optimization services they
always use of analyzers for sharing size
range analysis because agarose gels to
variable and easily affected by not only
by this percentage of the job but also
by voltage that you run it the gel and
also the sample Communications has been
loaded if you notice at 100 to 200 base
/ fragments right away then that's a
great time to show that you are over
sharing using too much energy it's you
do not need to expose your sample to a
high amount of energy to share it
efficiently as long as you use focused
energy such as the larvae FA you can
easily share with very limited about 150
times less energy than a bath fornicator
and still get the shearing completed
much faster than a bath sonicator you
also always want to look for a nice
gradual reduction in size fragment size
and distribution over time that's a very
indication that you're maintaining your
app itself integrity and we also advise
people to carry out western blots of the
sheared chromatin using the same
antibodies that you use for IP to
monitor your APIs of integrity as your
optimizing you
chromatin sharing so thermal control is
very important so the smaller defragment
that you want to share your comment into
the greater the amount of energy that
you have to put in but if you cannot
control that energy then you easily can
damage your DNA and chromatin so again
I've shown you this the result before
150 times more energy required for what
the back sonicator as compared to
providers to share DNA the same is true
with from within and of course
temperature control and chip is even
more important because increased
temperature will start reversing the
crosslands and so the you no longer have
in tex-ass epitopes so using a single
optimized protocol it is possible to
optimize a very very reproducible chip
sample preparation for any mammalian
cells or tissues in less than a week and
let's go through some of the examples of
people who are entities in kavars about
the focus acoustics here's from
genentech in which raw monocytes were
used as you can see the bottom plan is
with a buyer after vaginal baths on
decatur as you can see it takes quite a
lot even up to 30 minutes cheering
you're not getting sharing results top
panel with the kavars about the focused
acoustics within 15 minutes the
chromatin is all sheared less than five
hundred base pairs so this is a slide is
from a mouse lymphoblast as you can see
a nice gradual reduction in size over
time and if you look at the percentage
of material after eight minutes
seventy-eight percent of the materials
sheared down to 150 to 700 phase fares
to the eight minutes which is what you
want to look for was was less than
fifteen percent of the material over 702
702 707 kb here's an example of sorted
cv34 selves sheared using our technology
fairly rapidly as you can see the nice
gradual reduction in size role and
distribution over
here's the enriched II South fixed at
two time points two and a half minutes
and five minutes and as you can see the
Western blot at the bottom at two and a
half minutes six station the epitope
binding is not as tight so at five
minutes fixation you have a very nice
tight binding to the epitope so in this
case the disgusting work will utilize
the five minutes fixation for their
experiments here's mouse embryonic stem
cells also process for two and a half
minute and five minutes fixation
optimization as you can see our to an
ominous fixation you have a much tighter
distribution of fragments as compared to
five minutes so what mouse embryonic
stem cells and blood drive primary cells
we typically advise people to not to fix
more than two and a half minutes red
room temperature here's another example
using primary thymocytes using Auto
cobarde sharing buffer which contains
point one percent SPS as well as the lab
offer which contains four to five
percent of cs as you can see with our
technology the the shearing is much
tighter the distribution is tighter as
compared to the higher SDS concentration
here's mcf-7 cells as you can see they
have seven and knock your areas you can
generate the same sharing profile as the
non knock on fire the same protocol can
be used for with a multiple cell line so
this is from the crowd filled up at
Stanford University in which they tested
before the call for 50 sites es solve as
all of New Year's fears and as you can
see they're getting very good sharing
your goals from all three cell lines
using the same exact protocol the phone
call also works with tissues so we have
protocols for tissue so this example the
customer used the tissue protocol for
success for mouse colon tissue as one of
the hct116 out using the sound based kit
as you can see using a nice gradual
reduction in size over time for sharing
they monitored using
Lester using chi soaked and as you can
see a diabetic remains fairly intact
even up to 20 minutes processing fat so
here's mouse liver tissue process using
the tissue kit and as you can see
seventy-eight percent of the material
after eight minutes was only four
percent of the material greater than 7
kb so that means it's perfect for chip a
mouse brain tissue again monitored using
a Western as well on the top insert
panel monitor for beta catenin as well
as is going to be as you can see you can
destroy epitopes even with our
technology so don't overshare so in this
case a six-minute processing time has
waited in 75% of the material within the
desired size range we do not need to
over process your samples being rinsed
off at UCSD so this is a mouse distill
lint as you can see nice gradual
reduction in size over time it is highly
reproducible and this is a justified
over layout fibers dependently path of
samples share the shear to the same size
range you can tune the size range
depending on the application the
sequencing platform that you're using
you can easily tune it to the size range
that you need depending on the sequencer
so it is a different approach to
chromatin cheering we can utilize lower
cell numbers to reduce South culturing
it's a control cheering sighs oh so you
can tune it with only NGS platform that
you might be using it's an isothermal
process that maintains episode of
integrity during processing and we
utilize ultra-low detergent
concentrations so you can directly use
your material for IP without having to
dilute your samples and we have been
able to lower the fixation time
requirements which means that you have
more of the chromatin available for IT
and it's a universal protocol there's
guaranteed to work with all mammalian
cells and this allows highly
reproducible progress insurance for your
lab work we do have an ultra low sound
protocol that utilizes a hundred
thousand thousand dress and it's already
been published by fax it off it's a very
simple protocol you just fix in crunch
yourselves wash it and shears in our
buffer and go through the IP process
here's a an example of that as you can
see the shearing is nice and gradual
over time and after i pee you're
actually pulling down exactly the same
size range as you I keep we have
additional trip applications also for
plant chippies chip from your supply
runs the elegant and there are a few
publications in which our technology has
been used for ffpe chip an example of
some of the publications today excuse me
so we have a variety of different focus
ultrasonic aiders and that all has been
optimized for all the applications that
I've mentioned today such as DNA sharing
for NGOs grave DNA as well as extraction
of DNA and RNA from a fatty tissues as
well as chip so you can contact your
local representative which is you can
obtain that information from our website
you can contact them directly for
product information if you have any
applications or questions please feel
free to contact me my email address is
below as well as application support at
Guevara Singh Kham if you have any
questions with regards to technical
support you can access technical support
at Kivar Singh Kham and if you have any
questions with regards to purchase on an
instrument or kids or trial of an
instrument please contact international
sales at kavars inc com thank you very
much for for attending this webinar I
will take some questions now thank you
I had my colleague shy when he and if
you have submitted questions and a
Chinese he will be translating for me
for the Q&A session thank you very much
okay so here are some questions then I
will go through it so the first question
is what makes kavars about the focus
acoustics so unique one it is a patented
technology as I mentioned earlier it
utilizes medical grade transducers and
is very similar to technology that's
used in therapeutic as well as
diagnostic ultrasound we focus on the
acoustic energy to a very small focal
point we control the heat it's an
isothermal method of processing is so
it's a quite unique method of processing
your samples very efficiently and very
reproducibly so here's a question it is
what should i do a few sample floats on
top of the micro tubes doing differently
paralyzation stage well the current
protocol states that you need to add 100
microliters of the license bumper to the
FFP section and then process it there
there won't be any additional volume for
it to float and during the 302nd
processing the paraffin will be
micronized it come out of solution and
you'll see the solution turn cloudy so
that should not be a problem at all so
you have another question that says for
extraction of genomic DNA from a few
samples can if a partially fragment the
genomic DNA yes if you want this as I
showed in the protocol
in the presentation today there are
options in which you can extract a shear
and extract at the same time to a
variety of size ranges and it's easily
tunable you can extract 150 basement
fragments 200 300 400 500 it's up to you
or you to if you can if you choose you
to you can not share at all and extract
the highest possible fragment size which
in our hand tend to be about 8 kb so
another question is does the new
evolution EA require a different tube
holder for FFP extraction yes the
evolution does come with different
holders for the different tube types so
that should be it's a fairly evidence
and you can obtain that information from
us from from ours actually from
international sales and prove arson
combi can provide you more information
on the holder types and rock types that
are available for the evolution okay so
another question in your experience for
their 50 extracted DNA and RNA which is
more important quantity or quality in my
opinion quality is a lot more important
than quantity if you extract as i showed
in the data if you extract 10 times more
of the biased DNA would that give you
better coverage in terms of sequencing
unfortunately not so it's always best to
look at the yield because of course your
library proper will have a minimum
requirements of DNA for your sample prep
but quality is more important than me up
in our hands yes is it possible okay
let's see another question preparation
is necessary to perform up to treat FFP
sample with AFA and what kids do you
recommend well
ffp samples preparing ffp using to
extract its from tissue section 2
purified DNA so you don't need another
test to prepare your DNA I fear talking
about library prep there are multiple
kids out there for library pub we do
prefer the the Kappa hyper kids for the
low amount and put amount DNA okay let's
see all right it says you should that we
news kovar cfa to remove the paraffin
what happens to the paraffin once
removed well the paraffins removed in
micron size particles that remain fairly
inert and does not prevent the Bernie
escape from digesting the tissue and it
does not affect the purification because
it is retained in the column and does
not ask through so perfect is fairly
alert and it does not affect it but its
removal is essential because if you
don't remove all the paraffin you cannot
hydrate the tissue and it won't be
accessible for furnished case I just and
I think a few questions might have been
submitted in Chinese shuttle showing
were there do you want to give me a
couple of those questions before we end
the webinar okay it seems we've ran out
of time thank you very much for
attending the webinar the questions that
i did not get to well we will certainly
get to and will contact you via email
what would answers to those questions
once again thank you very much for
attending this webinar and we very much
look forward to talking to you further
these applications thank you